I wanted to talk about a little bit more
on some of the reactions to what
happened I'm by no means trying to stir
up any more of it and ultimately this is
my fault I'm the one responsible and the
more time that passes the more I and
more I realized that how wrong I was but
a lot of people's outrage or uproar
about it was pretty interesting maybe
you saw this tweet but it's from Sean
Vann whatever we're filing a DMCA
takedown of peopie thyroid content and
any future Campo Santo Games followed by
there is a bit of leeway you have to
have with the internet when you wake up
every day and make video games there's
also a breaking point I'm sick of this
child getting more and more chances to
make money of what we make for those who
don't know a DMCA claim is basically a
copyright strike it's like a legal
action towards your channel it's a
pretty big deal if I get more than three
of them then my channel will shut down
so you could say this is an attack on me
my livelihood so it seemed more than
just grandstanding this seems more like
an attack to me he also followed with I
urge other developers and will be
reaching out to folks much larger than
us
to cut him off from the content that has
made him a millionaire
so basically urging other people to do
the same I don't know a lot of people
aren't really sure about Let's Plays
it's sort of like a gray area in legal
terms because it's not like we owned the
game we don't own direct licence to it
and I don't think technically we can
sell the video with us in it and there
hasn't really been a trial that tests
this as well there hasn't really been a
trial that confirms yes Let's Plays are
protected by fair use you can't do
copyright takedown claims on them but
generally there hasn't been a case
because developers benefit massively
from let's players or streamers this is
pretty commonly known
and minecraft is a billion dollar title
because of streamers largely because of
streamers and youtubers same thing you
know pub gee I don't think it probably
would not be even nearly as big without
streamers and developers know this this
is pretty commonly known and that's why
even though yes we are making money
through your game it's still seen as
something positive but it is sort of
interesting to me this case in
particular because Sean's game is very
much probably the most linear game in
question you know it out of all games
that could have been talked about you
know it's to me it's really interesting
how a game like Firewatch talks about
this in a way like this because
Firewatch is an extremely linear game
it's almost like a walking simulator
it's not a bad game I quite enjoyed it
but arguably if you play Call of Duty
and someone else play Call of Duty
you're gonna get a completely different
experience almost no matter what but if
you play Firewatch you're probably gonna
have the exact same experience no matter
who plays it so you could say okay well
what's the difference between playing
the game yourself rather than just
watching someone else play it then and
ya know it's a fair point
and I think especially with Firewatch in
mind personally I think either way is
wrong you you're bringing in more
attention to the game people generally
want to play the games himself almost no
matter what even games that are pretty
much just a story base where you click
through and read people want to play
themselves and Firewatch compared to
other walking simulators like The
Walking Dead or life is strange it
doesn't really have choices that leads
to different outcomes or different
endings so it's it's it is very much on
the line and I think there was some
controversy as well with this game in
the past because people refunded the
game because it was so short and they
didn't like the ending and people were
streaming it so they were just worried
that people were just watching it
instead of buying it so I think it's you
know out of all people to come out of
make a statement like this I think it's
interesting that this is the developer
that did it that's pretty much my point
here furthermore we're complicit and I'm
sure we made money off the 5.7 million
views that video has and that's
something for us to think about now
let's get into the meat of this a lot of
people are saying I've seen a lot of
tweets saying then they're not abusing
copyright laws let's place because Let's
Plays aren't fair use get over it
I can't say for sure Nick that it is
protected against fair use but I'm
fairly certain and most legal expert
would say the same there are some
arguments against it but if you watch my
video you know that I'm adding my
commentary to it I'm gaming my inside to
it whoever watches me play it is gonna
experience it differently than anyone
that plays it themselves that's just how
it is there was an interesting article
about this as well saying haven't seen
some of pewdiepies fire watch let's play
video it definitely would appear to be
protected by fair use the fact that
Veneman directly and publicly admits
that he's not taking the video down for
any valid copyright reason but rather
because he thinks PewDiePie is a
propagator of despicable garbage doesn't
help venomous case at all
rather it gives PewDiePie a lot more
leverage to claim that any such tank
down would be abusive and possibly even
a violation of DMCA's against myths
representations I've also seen other
legal experts claiming that the video
isn't protected by fair use Let's Plays
aren't protected by fair use no one can
really say for certain that's why it's a
gray area there are other legal experts
saying that less plate aren't legal
Firewatch diem says our legal Deb's can
easily destroy YouTube channel and the
law isn't how you want it listen here
the thing though that a lot of people
pointed out shortly after these tweets
were made was that they have a stream
policy on their website this is
literally if you go to fire watch
game.com slash about it says can I
stream this game can I make money off of
those streams yes
we love that people stream and share
their experience in the game you are
free to monetize your videos as well so
people pointing this out but there's
still arguments against saying it
doesn't matter because let's play still
aren't fair use so they can do whatever
they want and I would I would agree
because basically Sean said he will he
will strike down any one of my future
lights plays and the current the past
one but the thing is that doesn't mean
he can go back and revoke from the old
one do you know what I'm saying
basically sean has the right to strike
any video that I upload from this point
because he's publicly said that that's
what he's gonna do but you can't
retroactively Lee go and say you know
what I'm revoking this license because
you are a racist garbage or whatever
that's not how DMCA work and I I'm
pretty sure that in that form of
selection bias is not gonna hold up in
court
imagine if I made some artwork and I
told people hey you're free to use his
artwork go ahead everyone people start
using the artwork and then I point to
some people say no and file a copyright
law dispute against that doesn't really
add up does it so regardless if let's
play is fair use or not this argument of
claiming my video is incorrect most
likely if my video gets striked I can't
really do anything about it YouTube
really doesn't they're sort of washing
their hands around these copyright
things they kind of want to leave out of
it I mean they've been sued enough so it
sort of makes sense I am NOT Jenn if a
case like this goes to court then
there's not gonna be much leverage for
it if anything it would be a huge waste
of time and money for Sean and his
developing team when I saw these tweets
I immediately privatized the video out
of respect for his request but my video
got claimed anyway they got the strike
anyway which is pretty disappointing to
be honest as far as I'm concerned I
didn't
use any abusive language in this video I
didn't do anything that I think would be
considered offensive this video was
uploaded as far as I know two years ago
and I gotta say I'm pretty disappointed
also in people defending this that I
know personally have had problem with
DMCA request takedown requests as well
whether you like me or mr. vanaman the
these laws are made to for people to
take down content and whenever there's
power to do so it's going to be abused
and especially when the reason to take
down the content has nothing to do with
copyright it's it sort of shows that I
think these laws are important and for
people for artists to protect artists
work and what they do and I think and
that's why I think it's really dangerous
to make these sort of claims and to do
these sort of copyright claims for no
real valid reason no matter what you
think of me if you have a problem with
any Content online or any video being up
you're afraid to tweet me I will
probably see it and I will respect that
request I did get a request from another
developer asking the same thing hey can
you delete this video and I did and I
wouldn't have any problem to have done
the same with this video I have a huge
amount of respect for developers and
what they do I know my my work would not
have been possible without them and
that's why I would never go against that
I could probably fight this in court and
I would probably win but I decided to
just delete the video and not waste
everyone's time more about this like I
said this everything about this was my
fault the whole drama I'm the one
starting it but I still think it's an
interesting discussion to talk about and
I think it's important that we don't
abuse these laws because they exist to
protect artists not to make any form of
censorship or abusive claims this video
is not meant to attack Sean or its
development team or anyone I just think
it's important to talk about these
things like I said I thought Firewatch
was a really great game and
I wish him all the best in the future
with their next title